you
hello there the Enigma of the seven has
been growing for years and finally at
the end of last season they were all
reunited fighting for the same cause to
reclaim the island and free the zero
point yet new information seen in the
zero War comic book series has given us
a new perspective on those events and
ninjas everything these events took
place while we were preoccupied in the
paradigm's mech assisting her in
bringing it home and defeating IO once
and for all it turns out the Avengers
were here in full force and a new
storyline is born I'll link the full
series of videos if you need a refresher
like the time they fought dinosaurs or
Wolverine and the imagined bumped uglies
or Doctor Doom attempted to steal the
zero point Shard all those things
happened in other episodes but today we
are back on dry land reality zero
Iron Man Foundation Paradigm imagined
Spider-Man shuri and Wolverine land back
on the island after their trip to the
ice Moon immediately we are told about
the Doomsday Machine which is now
complete and will eliminate everyone on
the island permanently if we don't stop
it the Paradigm thanks the scientist for
her new armor which he must have been
working on during season one of the
chapter whilst he was sending
Intergalactic Love Letters to her to
rejoin the seven hey paradigms so
um so far I've refrained from laying a
guilt trip on you like my mom used to do
all the Marvel characters in the group
are given a new suit Iron Man Has a new
version of the Hulkbuster combined with
seven Tech and Peter Parker has become
your friendly Omniverse Spider-Man the
foundation makes your Stark understands
that Tech will not be leaving the island
none of our Tech leaves reality zero
Iron Man so enjoy it while you can
Wolverine on the other hand doesn't want
a suit he likes the way he is and shuri
also rejects new clothing too to keep
wakandan gear on next we have a series
of reminders little callbacks to things
that have happened in the comic book run
we are reminded that Jones is at least
200 years old and everyone he has ever
loved has died
hide the pain bro the order aggressively
squares up to Logan confronting him
about the deed he did with her sister
but it turns out she's happy the
imagined got some action and hugs
Wolverine the calling card of fortnite
comic books is that in each series a
fish sticks will die giving us
information
cue Triggerfish this time he stumbles
over and dies in the arms of the
scientist passing across all Intel
needed about defeating IO and the
collider fish sticks are true heroes
this is the third one we've seen pass
away in our arms think back to issue one
and further back to the Batman series 2
R.I.P fish sticks
we watch as the leader the foundation
lays out plans which we already
perfectly executed during the collider
event dismantling Shield generators
while pushing forward to the tower
itself to be honest if we read this
before the live event it would have
added so much to it but alas that didn't
happen we are next reminded that storm
and Thor had kept the moon habitable for
the entirety of this series increasing
the temperature on the Moon preventing
the snow from freezing everyone
instantly and now they have a chance to
sit out they don't want to they want to
be part of the final battle Thor
proclaims for Earth for reality zero for
the Omniverse it's time we cut to the
battle for the island the mech lands and
the fight begins oh and let's address
the elephant in the room the mech in the
comic book and the mech in the live
event don't have the same color scheme
but we are assured they are exactly the
same the production looks like it
suffered quite a lot from lack of
communication or maybe this was all
finalized before the live event but
let's not concentrate on the weak Parts
on with the story as Paradigm and the
crew approached the collider to end the
fight she slips the ground gives way and
the mech falls into the cabin below hold
on
this is the opportunity for The Avengers
to step up Iron Man attempts to take
charge but he's instantly hit with a
bolt he describes as Thanos levels power
this is serious and then it happens we
finally see Geno the Enigma has revealed
himself up to this point we've only seen
him as shadowy figures instantly filled
with anger the imagined and the order
rushed to confront him their own father
before we get to see what happens with
the sisters we jump cut into the cavern
below Dr Doom and Gunner are speaking it
is revealed in the last episode Doom had
a different mission on the moon he
wasn't just there to grab The Shard of
the zero point he was sent to claim
other weapons of power from the Ice
King's collection any one of those items
we walked past could now be in Doom's
possession Doom could turn this fight in
the favor of IO but instead plot twist
Dr Doom doesn't care for this war and
opens a portal to return home he admires
the io's attempt to create the perfect
Society but he'd rather do it on his own
he's out of here back above ground to
the Family Feud General tries to reason
with his daughters offering to send them
to another reality instead of unaliving
them but he grows tiresome of the fourth
person in this battle Wolverine has been
scratching away at his back the three
Heroes work together to jam Geno's
flight system in an attempt to throw him
into the zero point jenno shouts you're
mad if we hit the zero point it'll tear
us apart and Scatter our bodies
throughout the Omniverse he's not wrong
we've seen it before with our very own
eyes when Batman came to visit
of Batman when the Eternal Voyager ran
and jumped straight into it it ripped
him to shreds the sisters are prepared
to pay the ultimate price and all four
fall towards the zero point Logan sneaks
hold of the wall in a last-ditch attempt
to survive also catching the order too
they then watch as Geno and the imagined
fall to their doom and if you remember
during the cavern part of the collider
event we actually saw those two fall
into the zero point they use different
character models back then but it was
all to keep the Enigma Wolverine and the
order have lost the imagined but wait
there's a snapback to reality idiot it
didn't work proclaims the order jenno
re-emerges from the zero point wipe
these failures out of existence you
next we see the live event from another
perspective Jones is begging Sloane to
reconsider her Allegiance and well you
know the rest of it
um look out with the help of the
Avengers we destroy the collider's power
source the Battle Is Over the zero point
is free yet there is more after the
foundation and John's leapt into the
zero point pursuing Geno they catch up
to him in this weird world Between
Worlds he emotionally bids farewell to
his daughter the two are slowly being
ripped apart by the zero point force yet
Geno is strong enough to slow down the
entire process just long enough to
reveal a few more truths Geno has never
been the bad guy at least in his own
mind he wanted to free all realities and
by controlling the zero point he was
actually protecting it looking at it
this season he may have a point about
the zero point it's been crying out for
helpful weeks and now the world is
becoming the nothing damn it Jenna was
the good guy Journal meets his end and
admits it's good to lay down the burden
of controlling the zero point he's been
doing this for hundreds if not thousands
of years his last words though are a
complete violation who's the blonde
fellow General really didn't know who
Jones was after working with him for at
least 200 years and that's gotta hurt
hide the pain bro General disintegrates
Before Their Eyes foundation and Jones
hit a knuckle bump and return back to
reality zero Geno is defeated
the story ends with the Avengers
returning home to reality 616 Jones
bonds with shuri Thor bonds with the
scientist and Wolverine attempts to bond
with the order but this lady has changed
something is different about her she
proclaims she will never visit
reality616 but if she sees Wolverine
ever again she will unmake him the order
walks away desperately trying to control
her anger finally the two leaders
foundation and Iron Man Who first made a
pact on the battlefield as bullets flew
by once again shake hands the armor Bros
have made a bond to last a lifetime
please go home Iron Man that's not the
end there's a bomb shelter this ending
Geno may have been ripped to pieces and
across realities but he's still alive
his body reconnects slowly across
multiple realities Jano isn't done jenno
is alive the zero war is now complete
but what has just begun jump forward to
where we are in fortnite right now only
one of the seven is still standing the
Paradigm she may not know about the
demise of the imagined but she
definitely saw the end of the scientist
origen and the visitor maybe we sent
home The Avengers a little too soon I'm
Adam you're awesome I'll see you next
time
[Music]